hey guys Ryan right here and this
morning I'm gonna be like to the TV spot
for Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
brothers I'm already excited to watch
this I know there's been mixed reactions
about it when I saw the first filler I
got really pumped this movie to me it
looks like it's just gonna be a great
entertaining time I love the turtles I'm
okay with different interpretations when
people do stuff I believe that Hollywood
just like you know like when people who
create novels and comic books based off
movies give their own interpretation of
the movie people don't complain about it
and I think Hollywood is allowed to do
the same thing with other sources or
they can adapt it but you know give its
own interpretation I mean there are a
few things I'm a little concerned about
like William Fichtner in a shredder yeah
he's a great actor I love him in a lot
of movies but he's white there's a
problem here the Turtles I kind of like
the fact that they look a little bit
creepy and not so cute what did they
look creepy in real life I don't imagine
they would look adorable creatures and I
don't really have a problem Megan Fox me
April O'Neil sure she's a [ __ ] actress
whatever so what I could jerk-off her
after the movies done and that's what
really counts
fine suey rap
women nothing is a strong there's
families tests look like a my letter
okay so it was a buncha knew about that
trailer but I did like how they showed a
little bit of splinter from the side I
really want to see splinter really clear
yeah this is gonna be a cool movie I
think I hope it's cool it does look a
little too Michael Bay ish I you know so
what sometimes Michael Bay does a good
job sometimes not really anyway guys if
you're new to the channel though
subscribe Michael Manjula does kind of
look like Shrek people are right about
that anyway guys I'm trying something
new here I'm gonna give some shoutouts
never done this before I'm so sorry
casting it's funny Jermaine woodford you
requested a shout out I liked your last
name any last name with wooden it is
[ __ ] hilarious beans I feel like a
good dick joke Jordan Jackson said he
will steal my face if I don't give him a
shout-out so here's your shoutout
[ __ ] leather face deep tally you
wanted to shout out so here it is you
get you'll [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh tally take
your tally
yo get tally you make me really happy
when you leave a comment below wouldn't
you know that sometimes I'll suck your
dick as I'm half homo what does it mean
to be half my guess it means being
bisexual take that sentence literal I
can [ __ ] you in the ass
it'd be physical why is everything I do
to turn into something big